i'm professor hannah fry a mathematician
and podcaster and i'm excited to tell
you about the return of deepmind the
podcast
it's the series where we go behind the
scenes of one of the world's leading
artificial intelligence companies
to find out how the latest developments
in ai
are transforming our world
you have techniques that can tackle some
of the hardest problems that have eluded
the brightest minds for decades i think
it's woken up the scientific world to
the possibility of what ai could do you
might have heard that last year a deep
mind system called alpha fold made an
enormous breakthrough by using ai to
solve a 50 year old grand challenge
what you're describing here is a
potential step change in all of
healthcare and medicine really that is
the implication of truly understanding
biology
for the very first time we'll hear the
inside story of alpha fold from the
people who were in the room where it
happened we had a meeting saying okay
are we going to solve this problem or
should we be doing something else that
we can solve what give up was that
really on the table oh that was
absolutely as a scientist you're always
making a bet throughout this series we
explore how artificial intelligence is
being applied to real world problems
from weather forecasting it is important
to know if there's going to be a build
up of a catastrophic storm to the
creation of synthetic voices like this
one when i'm not trying to crack one of
the unsolved millennium prize problems
you can find me chillaxing with a cup of
tea it's really good i know it's good am
i that breathy
we'll be exploring in detail deepmind's
efforts to create artificial
intelligence that can talk to humans
me
what's my worst feature model you're
going to get upset if i tell you
and even programming robots to learn to
walk by themselves looks like it's a
drunk robot well sort of so it's trying
to walk backwards but it's sort of um
it's given up and it's really flawn
but we haven't shied away from the tough
questions that deepmind's researchers
are asking as they develop the
technology of the future
the last set of people who said they
were going to advance science and
humanity created colonialism we cannot
be complacent about what it means to put
forward a mission like that into the
world
because the big north star of all of
this work at deepmind is to create an
advanced problem-solving system known as
artificial general intelligence or agi
the outcome i've always dreamed of is
agi has helped us solve a lot of the big
challenges facing society today
join me hannah fry for the second season
of deepmind the podcast coming soon to
wherever you get your podcasts